[Applaudissements]
moi je suis un orateur
salut thomas nides et tours ou baratin
je ne vous promet pas d'être les
chevilles tous les soirs mais juste de
qui fait oublier les histoires à tous
les dirigeants du monde f1 nous priver
d'un oeil neuf
franchement c'est pas mal hein
si vous m'écoutez pas joséphine ange
gardien avec deux doigts jeu
sur idée
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui on a le droit d'être invitée
chez nous
le patron
il y a
on
et pas
ap
on est ravi
nous
[Musique]
à
et un jour c'était le cas aujourd'hui
la peur de l'être des clauses mais la
veille
jour 2 0
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ba aa
bah
on a
ma forme
m
o o
si l'euro
ce faire
faux pas
[Musique]
aujourd'hui au tac
chez eux
lula
[Applaudissements]
de beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
nouveautés ce soir beaucoup de films
beaucoup de dark horse
alors vous allez allez vous mettre un
mot de passe chacun votre tour mais
alors je vais reprendre dans l'orne
alors vous donc vous vous êtes donc vous
tous et les animateurs de démarque des
légendes et d'autres où la tristesse
vous êtes c'est la question
c'est la question qui
[Applaudissements]
à côté de lui à babu babou jeu c'est bah
oui regardez laurence boccolini benali
le magenta
[Applaudissements]
si vous trouvez de tf1 vous allez me
voir
franchement c'est incroyable alors sur
le vide n'est alors plus qu'une femme
est ce que vous êtes donc sur tf1
chotai choix depuis très longtemps de
fait la création depuis la création des
paris sur le public a une idée pour
l'instant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quant à toi tu m'as donné l'aura
d'ailleurs demain on aura la vraie
d'ailleurs demain il se france laisse
contrat avec le violent ou d'être très
belle aussi
kelly b novelli merci aux amis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans la loge le mec qui me disait
navarro je m'étais carte
mais si ça te plait pourrait très bien
merci bas c'est bon tu crois que ce soir
merci de ma passe par là bah ouais alors
aurait pu sortir entre 1912 mais bon
quand même plein mais je vous jure vous
êtes magnifique gibbons bombe de cabinet
pommier un maillot de bain cette offre
lui manque une bonne miss france à 100 m
est ce qu'elle a fait alors c'est génial
de fonder que chez le dentiste
eric naulleau
alors eric naulleau bats toi et toi
bande a compris que c'était mon frère
c'est fait c'est qui
alors ok mais tu vas me dire c'est
l'animatrice que j'adore je suis fou
d'elle est lisse et g2 mais animatrice
préférée c'est qu'ils lcd gay alessandra
sublet bravo alors lui sur la tête de ma
mère
au début je les veux arriver mais vous
êtes qui monsieur non mais c'est
horrible c'est qui c'est qui mais vous
êtes trop soir mais marquez mais c'est
bien
[Applaudissements]